if you think the best thing to come out
of Kentucky is chicken well you'd be
wrong
Kentucky's also home to a very unusual
piste the Kraken creators Eric Andy and
Steve filmed their quest to turn a used
propane tank into a submarine and over a
hundred thousand people noticed I love
these guys there's not wine of pink fit
that I get inside it
we're farmers and for that submarine
builders basically made out of just a
bunch of stuff we had leftover for
making other things propane tanks are
great at holding pressurized gas but how
can they also be used to build a
submarine the biggest problem with a
submarine is the pressure from the water
and propane tanks are built with exactly
that in mind they're there to withstand
pressure admittedly they're meant to
contain pressure pushing out and a
submarine has to stop pressure pushing
in but it's exactly the same structure
this cylindrical shape the circular
cross-section is perfect what it does is
it evenly spreads the force out there's
no weak points and because of that it
can withstand a lot of pressure so
they've created a perfect all from
backyard parts but what else does it
take to get to the bottom of a lake
but here we have the ballast tanks that
what we feel with air or water to the
sand or descent when you fill it with
water the submarine is now more dense
and the surrounding water so it's going
to sink down when you want to rise back
up you fill it with air and now the
submarine is lighter and is going to
rise back up but to enjoy the underwater
vistas they needed portals so what other
spare parts do they find lying around
these rings are on a bag actually go on
a green system the downspout on a green
bin and I had laying around extra and I
thought we weld them on they work fine
unfortunately because that made a few
changes I've put in windows and controls
and that'll give you weak points the
structural integrity as we call it could
break at those points we limited
ourselves to like 35 feet just for a
safety factor just going 10 meters down
which is 33 foot that means the pressure
on the hole would be twice the
atmospheric pressure even though that
doesn't sound that impressive it really
is these guys actually built one and got
in it and went underwater and survived
I'm impressed
when you go under and nothing's leaking
and you're able to submerge it feels
like a great accomplishment when we
touch it down on the bottom and that's
whenever I realized hey this actually
happened and there's just one more thing
what's up with the paint scheme you know
the yellow submarine everybody's heard
that song and we're well that's why we
didn't paint it yellow because it's just
it's different this way you know
everything everybody expects it to be
yellow saw you wanting something
different